Adam Carolla is a comedian a TV host a
director and a podcast king he's created
starred in and guessed it on many TV
shows such as the man show catch a
contractor Dancing with the Stars in
Celebrity Apprentice Adam thanks for
joining me Dave
thanks for having me Glendale we Ora and
you mm-hmm creating the new Hollywood of
Glendale yeah well you know Glendale the
thing about Glendale and Oran it's
always been sort of a I don't know if
you know this but people have always
made this spiritual pilgrimage Glendale
yes all right game in a lot of you know
folks coming in here trying to find
themselves and so that's why aura
obviously settled in Glendale yeah so
it's sort of like the mecca of it's a
sort of if la had a sedona that it would
be glendale so it's that oh and a lot of
malls in Armenian people a lot of malls
here a lot of eagles I think I I don't
know who came first our minions are the
malls but I think Armenian people must
love malls yeah
maybe it's a tradition maybe like their
great was the ball invented in Armenia
you think well it started with a group
of Armenians aimlessly wandering in a
circle yeah in a space and then somebody
went this should be a Cinnabon and then
that was like the first you know then
somebody went then then Orange Julius
yeah and somebody else went and then one
of the Armenians who was a little more
entrepreneurial started putting up the
first you know steak Shake Shack or
whatever they have over there yeah we
get in the Shake Shack around here we
have we have an in and out that's good
enough for me
you know what a public said too much
obviously I'm privy to information that
you're not yeah you've been in the
committee there's a Shake Shack or Steak
and Shake or Shake steak and egg coming
or fake steak shake it's all I just like
the fact that we're not fat enough like
what do we need do we do can we do can
we stuff something in a hot dog on a
stick or well it's already hot yeah but
what if we put cheese in
side the hot so we say don't put them no
no dip it in the batter just put the
cheese alright what if we just what if I
but funnel Velveeta while I eat that
well we could do that but it we'd be
better off just putting the Velveeta in
the cheese and oh then we'll put the
whole thing in the crust of a pizza now
you've got even the hotdogs on hold on
we take the liquid cheese we'll put it
in the hot iron stick we'll roll that
into the crust of the pizza now you have
mangry oh that but that's just a drink I
mean we clearly should be going into the
service I should be I have mangria I
have a endless rant IPA with young
people seem to enjoy a lot and I should
be in the food business because I think
I just invented a hot dog on a stick
cheese infused pizza crust
yeah will delay this posting so that you
can make do the necessary legal work
together or oh I'm gonna start a place
at the mall called middle of the stick
where I just pull the stick out of hot
dogs on a stick and you just eat the
weird little burnt batter that's in the
middle of the stick yeah just the means
you have to buy it you know you're an
idea guy if you're buying bulk like 37
of those just it just to start taste in
it yeah you know we just it's the middle
of the stick this end just smells of
hotdogs this and just has a pube on it
but the middle the middle is what you
which you get middle of the stick
yeah you do realize that some people are
gonna be into this I mean there are
people right now on YouTube going that
sounds pretty good to me yeah I know I'm
a man other people you are a man of the
people speaking of a man of the people
let's get the the elephant in the room
out of the way you are a straight white
cisgendered upper class man mm-hmm
pretty much the most hated thing in
America yeah just so explain yourself
apologize if you want to talk directly
the camera how do you want to deal with
this let's just go well I have this
great benefit in that
I I find that a lot I have a couple
approaches to this
I always said you know I can be an
[ __ ] because I'm not an [ __ ] I can
say things that are asinine because I'm
not a bad guy like like if you're a bad
person you can't say bad things like
remember the old Rosie O'Donnell yeah
remember her show in the nine of course
of course cutie patootie chub Club I got
a crush on Tom Cruise yeah yeah
I got a lot of pastel going on yeah yeah
there was a laugh as you think that was
a real Rosie right
I guess that your point what do you
think what's behind that facade now
Rosie this is Rosie yeah I like this
Rosie by the way but do you see what
that was
mm-hmm there was a compensation for who
Rosie is and who she knows in her head
right you know I mean like people say to
me you're racist and I go if I was a
racist I wouldn't make so many races
jump cuz I'd be worried that people find
out I was a racist right no one's
claiming you're dumb you'd have to be
dumb to be doing yes yeah I went to a
wedding they had a full life Orchestra
big to-do everyone was dancing
except for Ellen now that sounds like
one of those like Geico commercials like
they're happier than Ellen for hours no
dancing really yeah so here's the
question does she love dancing Wow or
maybe she just gets it all out of her
system at the beginning of the show yeah
or maybe she wants you to think she's
the kind of person who loves dancing are
you saying that people on television
aren't all incredibly genuine some of
them may be wanting you to think one
thing about them and then turns out they
may be different people yeah so maybe
Ellen doesn't like dancing that much or
and maybe Rosie when she's done shooting
nerf balls at the audience goes
backstage and fires a bunch of [ __ ]
producers and directors see maybe that's
what
there's an entertainer and a business
person there which you know there's you
obviously no ality so for me I just sort
of I try not to have a chasm between Who
I am in front of the camera behind the
microphone and just who I am yeah
just Who I am but I have a thing which
I'm kind of lucky and unlucky which is I
grew up six miles from here and in North
Hollywood in basic poverty you know mom
food stamps and Welfare and and all that
stuff and then I then when when I was
done with high school just cleaned
carpets and dug ditches and clean
garbage on a construction site so I
don't really have that part like I was
watching Bill Maher show and Bill was
talking to some CEO or something and he
was explaining that he he used to be
poor and then I thought when was built
he went to Cornell
that's an ivy school everyone had that
everyone technically when you're 22 eats
Top Ramen
yeah and drinks Shafer beer they don't
drink Anchor Steam and eat sushi there's
that little window when you're poor but
I don't think that's what people are
talking about I don't think Oh people
love that right before you don't think
Cornell grad don't think Ivy League at
all I don't okay al not a lot of Yale
brought where people know a lot of
president we do a lot of we do a lot of
like hey I know what it's like and
that's the new sort of black you know
what I mean like that's the new vogue
thing is to go pours the new black
actually not being poor growing up poor
right and then if you do make money you
got to go Michael Moore Michael Moore
has worth is 50 million dollars in the
bank dresses like an out-of-work lesbian
trucker so what is Michael or what is
his facade right what's Rosie doing
what's Michael Moore doing shows up on
TV wearing a cargo shorts in one
flip-flop right it's like hey
buddy got fifty million dollars in the
back and that old hat yeah like at any
one time some Dockers
yeah probably step up what are doctors
like twenty three dollars so that that's
real I mean baby is your money is tied
up in real estate yeah I got it maybe
he's not liquid enough to get some
doctors maybe that's it man being for
another guy maybe his 50 million is all
in cattle and he just can't free it up
like you can't sell one cow it could all
be umber giri's me it could be barriers
yeah either way maybe Michaels not
liquid and listen I like Michael right
and I like uh I like Bill Maher I like
those guys but the point is is if you're
gonna be who you are you can't come
pullin up in a Rolls Royce these days
even though Michael Moore can afford a
fleet of Rolls Royces right he still
can't you got a you got to join the
masses
pretend you're one of them and then you
go back to your double gated community
right I'm just saying let's not be
hypocrites right so in the case of
someone like Rosie I think basically
what you're saying is that her evolution
is actually pretty great right she got
to where she was supposed to get but it
was really by getting away from
television actually right well she
didn't even get to where she was
supposed to get she just got to who she
always was yeah she just scraped away
the thick layer of marzipan and whatever
sugary goo she'd cover herself in yeah
to hide this inner I don't know angry
straight talking straightforward smart
funny in your face abrasive whatever
yeah to do syndicated TV you know it's
funny I grew up on Long Island which is
where she's from and did stand-up and I
loved her as a comic in the 80s on that
was that vh1 show they did remember
spotlight stand-up spotlight or
something like that like and then I sort
of missed those years of the Rosie
O'Donnell show but then I when she was
on the view I loved her and then we've
actually become friends so like I missed
that sort of faked chunk but I totally
hear you that everyone sort of picked if
you're in this business you pick this
idea of who you are
versus who you are well think about it I
mean Rosie O'Donnell's 55 or whatever
her age is she's doing a show in the 90s
mid-90s or later mid-90s the woman's in
well into her 30s
do you think she became a different
human being between her mid-30s and her
mid 40s when she started doing the view
like it's exact same person right you
need this person to do syndicated
television like daytime syndicated
television and at a certain point she
just realized it probably serve her
better to be herself yeah which I enjoy
but back to me yeah back to you so you
float I just give me my shelf yeah cuz I
don't feel like I have some inner a
swipe or racists or misogynist or
whatever or xenophobe that's hiding
within me that I have to kind of you
know like the preacher who's talking
about you know one man laying down with
another man might as well lay down with
a donkey or be stubborn in the next you
know there's AM Airport banging feet
with something yeah and it's like oh oh
that's who oh that's who he is
yeah not this guy right this guy is
Novak I know in advance he's this guy
cuz he's trying too hard being this guy
is there anyone out there who preaches
morality like a politician or a preacher
or anyone who isn't secretly doing some
of that stuff ah there anyone I can
think of is Jimmy Carter I mean he's got
a couple of women in Italian we call gu
Mao's on the side yeah it's got a couple
murders da Kuma's a couple yeah not even
a not even five but more than are you
talking about in the day we're now you
three-year-old yesterday yeah so besides
the womanizing
thing Jimmy Carter I'd say Jimmy Carter
would be the sort of morality yeah
you're not sterile
hey you know it's just one of those a
single mom I built you a house how about
a little something for the effort yeah
you know what I mean I've been out of
the game is Paul he's out there with
hammer I mean oh man I'm saying when you
give the keys you know what I mean by
hand
these are a single mom it's a little oh
there's ones they didn't tell you about
yeah you know I mean oh good you still
got the kneepads on from laying the
baseboard good good that works so
there's there's that yeah but other than
that and of course late great Carl Sagan
yeah I can't think of any my hero now
you're gonna tell he was a womanizer II
read all his books this is very
obsessive what was unity Martin Luther
King they're all don't hold it against
us guys are out there doing great work
yeah so you can't judge them for the
little mistakes that they had with those
kinds of transgressions I would I would
argue if you were to show me a chart I
think those guys were more successful
you know because because of it yeah
whatever they blew off a little steam
you know you know what I mean it's like
all the great all the guys who won World
War two for us were smokers you know
what I mean so you really want to get
rid of smokers what if another war
breaks out right that's a good point
we're screwed there's some point there
guys vaping going on definitely not
getting in a Higgins craft and I'm
definitely not going on that beat what
do you make of this vaping thing I see
these people walking around and they're
they're engulfed in smoke you know to me
like they're walking down the street and
it looks like their head is how is that
vaping wait that's vaping or which
there's one that there's like a shitload
of smoke that comes out and then there's
one that I guess no smoke comes out yeah
I I don't or somebody that I know this
is really messed up vaporize I like the
people who vape and smoke just the whole
thing what do we do well I took a
cigarette I crush it up I put it in the
vape and I actually rolled a nicotine
patch around it a shove that in there
too so yeah I like those people I like I
like the ones that blow up I like the
fact that we've I like the fact that God
is punishing us because we went luck
here's the deal there's two items
there's two items this year brand-new
items that have been blowing up and
catching on fire one is the the
electronic cigarette yep because man has
either become too lazy to smoke or too
lazy to quit smoke
we invented this in between like robot
stick that smokes for us yeah and then
the other thing is the Segway thing oh
those things are those were those old
what yeah those things called yeah it's
not technically the Segway to the other
yeah that's skateboard version it's a
skate park but we've decided that like
24-year old rappers can no longer walk
through a lot there must be propelled so
what god did is he went you know what
I'm gonna have that [ __ ] catch on fire
in the middle of the night I mean is
there anything that look I'm an atheist
but I know acts of God yeah you're
firing up your electronic cigarette
everything blows up it takes out your
eye or this thing sitting in the hallway
recharging in the middle of the night
and burst into flames just spontaneous
how many all right let me ask ya
everyone has a cell phone the rulers
kajillions of cell phones do you turn on
the news and hear about them bursting
into flames
rarely really I'd say never yeah so I
have evidently the man upstairs is cool
with cell phones you realize that's a
way for us to communicate right but not
all right with this thing that's
equivalent my kid just got one yeah and
now the people first stuff the people
that should be on these things or people
in their 80s and night right exactly
generals that are able-bodied so what
kind of father are you you're buying
your kid one of these his legs are gonna
eat atrophy hypocritical hip totally
hypocritical
yeah I'm looking actually speaking
atrophy I'm looking to have the house
made into a zero gravity environment so
the kids literally could just float into
the kitchen stuff their face with some
pizza that's stuff the crust is stuffed
with corndogs and cheese and then flow
back they they'd see their hoverboard
floating by if their faith cigarettes
would be like maybe reaching be reaching
they'd be riding the hoverboard but
upside down and floating around with the
bait that smoke the vape what the vapor
wouldn't know where to go because it
would be like no gravity I'm pretty sure
that was the plot of wall-e wasn't as if
I remember Wally like when you just
become these fat Oh
consuming monsters that's where we are
but gods paying us back in the form of
fire so is that the reset is that like
the world just resetting like yeah I've
gone to sometimes technology is just
ridiculous guys on a hoverboard
yeah he's vaping boom it just goes up
like like one of those Yogi's protesting
the Vietnam War yeah a man just douses
himself and Foom
right now I'm convinced if you vape and
ride a hoverboard you will go up in a
ball of fire
yeah and it would be deserving wouldn't
you say would be deserving I don't know
that it would be deserving but whoever
that individual was he wouldn't be
missed
yeah not saying he deserves it I'm
saying not missed yeah you know I mean
like you hear about what happened to
Kirk I was riding this you know it's
hoverboard and he was vaping and
nobody's going oh this kind of went no
one went like oh man who's gonna pick me
up from the airport
yes yeah he's gone what we're gonna add
on a deck now Kurt's gone yeah nobody
cares about that guy nobody cares you
know I know you're a man of your word
because you have to get sponsors for
your show and you are right now making
it clear that you don't want the big
hoverboard money yeah I'm not into big
board or big vape but you know if the
folks from round table or Pizza Hut are
listening we may be able to collaborate
on a project you're down with that
actually when I did you show a couple
weeks ago you had a bag from that that
thing that the Sun charges the bag and
that your backpack on that back yeah and
then you can walk on it well that was
like you went like caveman interviewer
yeah Sun or fire I a cold cool thing
magic bag yeah I thought it was pretty
good I was like that thing's actually
that's a nice use of people like
backpacks you like having its back with
a solar panel in it and it won't run
your car or your pump you know for your
well water that thing connected to my
Tesla is that not gonna the Bott well I
have heard it yeah but it will power
your cell phone
right so if you're at the beach all day
and you want to listen to some tunes
from your cell phone by the way all
these activities I never participate in
and it's always pretty so it's like
let's say you're at the beach all day or
maybe you're snowboarding or maybe like
wakeboarding and I'm always like you've
never done anything right I do it I've
done everything and do nothing
you